[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the award-winning michael jackson
tribute show mj live i'm sorry
we're talking to everybody is
moonwalking
to the choppa king
there you go santana jackson hey guys
hey welcome
now you're moving to the top of canada
starting february 7th
absolutely and here to tell us about
yeah you were you were at the
stratosphere for what five years or so
right yeah and man the reviews have been
phenomenal the whole time we try to put
on a good show and make sure it's a
family-friendly show oh my gosh so what
can we expect tell everybody what the mj
live show is all about it's a it's like
watching michael in concert we bring the
magic to life we uh want you to feel
like you're seeing him in person and uh
well i feel like i'm seeing him in
person right now right he even gave us
i knew him yeah there you go
that was that was bad yeah oh no mine
was bad
exactly exactly okay so for the show you
know is there anything different that we
should expect um now that you're at the
tropicana we're gonna have a bigger
stage so we're definitely gonna bring uh
more action more uh more magic more of
the you know the michael experience
you don't normally get to see wow when
did you realize that you had this talent
you obviously have known you could sing
for a long time but when did you realize
wait i can sing like michael jackson
it took it took a little while i mean i
loved dancing so i was doing a lot more
of the dancing and i got into the the
vocals of michael and i was like you
know what maybe we can uh do something
with it now you know a lot of studying
listen to michael and how he sings stuff
in different keys and tones you know
kind of match them the best i can so did
you try it out on a bunch of people and
oh i used to walk up to everybody hi i
love you know you've seen tito i love
them too
full makeup all the time oh my gosh oh
my gosh so you and this obviously this
is just who you are at this point you
know
what when you're on stage what is the
act that mo gets you most excited the
one that we have to make sure we are po
we are focused on my favorite song
really to to and to get down to dance to
you is a billie jean oh yeah my door
yeah it's just you get all them you get
the moonwalking the classic you know the
dance steps the movie just the attitude
would bring the same power michael
michael brings himself so when you when
you're not and this is a tremendous
costume i mean really you look like
michael jackson when you're not in
costume would anybody recognize you ever
not all the time not a lot of people do
but some people actually you know they
look at my face or they start paying
attention because i wear a hat right i
stay with the shoes on
a little there's always something you
know the glasses i keep the glasses on
all the time so yeah me with the glasses
plus i have my own it's my hair so you
know wow
oh my god look look at those locks
okay so of course since we have you here
you already moonwalked for us but we
need to see a couple more moves
absolutely
and
so this is from black or white
right here
oh no you can do is this like in out in
out and
you just pick up the face
there you go and then add a little kick
a little spin
wait
starting february 7th at the traffic
camper mj live sanjana jackson wow
thank you incredible incredible
i love it
okay we can do this forever you guys
let's move on to in today's
entertainment headlines the stars share